[Musique]
depuis plus de 30 ans le département de
la réunion soutient les échanges avec
les pays de la zone
c'est dans cette optique qu'a été signé
ce mercredi 5 juillet un partenariat
avec la fondation de l'alliance
française
grâce à cette convention les volontaires
réunionnais pourront plus facilement
miser sur leur insertion professionnelle
ailleurs qu'à la réunion cette
convention est une forme de finalisation
du travail réalisé depuis quelques
années et qui met justement en
perspective le reste de l'avenir du
département et de son partenariat avec
la fondation les alliances françaises
nationale quoi faire un projet partagé
dimension partenariat entre la réunion
du département de la réunion et la
fondation alliance française pour
développer la coopération permettre à
des volontaires de participer aux
actions de développement de la française
à la réunion et il ya déjà des
volontaires qui participent à des
actions conjointes
la langue française cela va leur donner
davantage de possibilités
d'être participants à ces actions ces
volontaires réunionnais auront
l'opportunité de se former dans
plusieurs pays de la zone océan indien
par le biais des réseaux de la fondation
de l'alliance française un véritable
atout à l'insertion par la mobilité
avons aujourd'hui nous 280 jeunes
réunionnais diplômés qui ont été formés
avec le cp de partenaires allaient
travailler dans les pays de la zone
madagascar les comores l'île maurice des
seychelles principalement pour faire de
la promotion de la langue française
l'accompagnement à la francophonie ça
marche très bien
nous sommes une alliance française de
pondichéry et nous avons déjà des
conventions avec les lieux dior on a
deux stagiaires qui travaillent avec
nous déjà à pondichéry
v
c'est une expérience qui est
habituellement très bien et social des
transferts de compétences et des
échanges de savoir faire à travers la
mobilité qui montre un engagement de la
part du département ainsi que de la
fondation alliance française
cela se traduit par la mise en place de
différents financements comme l'aide à
la mobilité avec le cnar mme ou la prise
en charge du salaire vous êtes formé
accompagné par le c ur et vous payez
votre billet d'avion et vous allez ou en
afrique du sud à madagascar dans tous
les pays je vous ai cités l'île maurice
les comores la chine l'inde et vous
pouvez travailler deux ans en étant payé
par nous dans les alliances dans les
ministères
vv conduit dans
jeunes moins jeunes sont tous
volontaires et demandeur de projets de
mobilité
et c'est dans ce sens qui font appel aux
plats qui est je le rappelle je leur dis
dans le dispositif du conseil général de
la réunion pour la mobilité vers
l'emploi mais trailer et c'est vrai
solis et nous avons deux mille personnes
chaque année qui nous sollicitent pour
partir en unissant leurs efforts le
département et la fondation de
l'alliance française donne l'opportunité
aux réunionnais de faire rayonner les
valeurs de la culture française bien
plus loin que dans la zone océan indien
l'opportunité de s'ouvrir au monde
[Musique]